it's gonna be a long episode if you see
me drinking coffee at the beginning of a
video fact if you see coffee in the
thumbnail of a video you know it's gonna
be a nice long episode hey what's up
guys my name is Chen and welcome back to
my game management series so last time
we talked about smart pointers
references we talked about assets as
well check out that video if you haven't
already and today I'm gonna start off by
actually creating probably our first
actual asset type right like we've got
shaders and we kind of consider them as
assets potentially and geometry that
we've kind of created in our engine but
today we're actually gonna load a file
from our computer it's gonna be any file
that you guys create yourselves we're
gonna load that in and we're gonna
display it in our engine this is really
exciting because if you haven't if you
haven't watched my video on what game
engines actually are literally the first
episode of this series so if you haven't
watched it I'm quite disappointed in you
but in that video we talked about the
fact that engines are really just these
kind of tools that we have we write all
this software this kind of engineering
ethic goes into this software this
program which takes data from our
computer and transforms it into some
interactive like graphics adventure that
we see on the screen that's really what
a game engine is and today we're finally
taking in a piece of data that isn't
generated from within like our engine or
anything like that we're going to be
learning in a texture just a normal
image file and actually displaying it on
our screen so that's super exciting so I
have a video on textures in OpenGL so
check that out as well if you haven't
yet that's gonna be kind of the basis
for what kind of code we write here
although the code we write here today is
gonna be a little bit different
specifically the opengl code that we
write here today
I mean we're also gonna set up like I'll
stand a kind of abstraction and
everything like that as we've done with
like different rent or primitives as I
called him like you know vertex array
and shader
but specifically like the OpenGL code is
going to be different because we'll be
using a bit more of the updated API
which I'm not quite sure windows 10
wants me to restart we'll stop with that
by the way like seriously almost makes
me want to switch to Mac you know not
really but almost this whole OpenGL API
is honestly such a mess that I don't
even want to
spend too much time talking about it but
we will be using something a little bit
newer than what we did like in that
OpenGL series specifically to do with
texture loading so I want to talk a
little bit about what textures actually
are and what they're used for in a game
mentioned because textures are extremely
powerful textures are very powerful
textures are more than you might think
they are you might be used to textures
just being like ok well I woke up I've
got an object like this bunny for
example this is why I've got the bunny
here so I can do things like this
we bought this Widow this bunny here and
I wanted to be green and I wanted to
kind of maybe the ears need to be some
other color and I just want it to be
more than just like one solid color so
how do I do that well I'll just kind of
create this 3d model in a program such
as blender Oh Maya or 3d max or anything
like that and then I'll texture it I'll
add like a credit-based belt I'll unwrap
the UVs and I'll flatten it all into a
texture and I'll paint that in Photoshop
and I'll just have my nice little bunny
and that's that's correct I mean that's
probably the first use of textures that
comes to mind but textures can be a lot
more than that because what textures
actually are what they actually are is
just just a buffer of memory that we've
taken and uploaded to our GPU announced
taught in our vram and we can access
that buffer of memory in our shader
specifically in our fragment shader in a
pixel shader when it's time to determine
you know what color to shade a given
pixel so because it's just a buffer of
memory we can upload anything into it I
talked a little bit about buffers like
our index bar for a new vertex buffer
and how like you know how vertex buffer
isn't just for positions we can put any
kind of data we want into their textures
are exactly the same you could literally
you could put anything you want into a
texture and then when you sample that
texture apart from getting all the
specific GPU technology that goes into
sampling a texture and determining like
you know what color to kind of
interpolate it into if we're doing
magnification or minification filtering
on an anisotropic filtering or any other
kind of filtering when we actually
sample a pixel and we determine what
color to return from that texture image
we get all of that bonus kind of data or
if we want it and then also we just have
the ability to you know shader just
select that kind of specific region of a
texture and be like I want to know what
the value is now true in many cases the
value is the color for example you know
maybe
bunnies fur color is brown so we'll just
get that brown color out and now our
bunny will be rendered as brown however
we can encode any kind of data we want
into into it a good really good example
as a normal mapping right where what
we've done is we've wanted to keep our
bunny model kind of low poly so that we
don't have to just have this hugely high
poly very heavyweight very performance
expensive like model 3d model with all
these little little details instead of
doing that we create a texture which is
just basically a little collection of
values which define more finally the
normals that go into this body and that
high-resolution texture with all that
kind of normal data and it can actually
help our bunny look a lot more detailed
and a lot more realistic because when
it's time for us to do our lighting
calculations instead of relying on the
vertex normals we can actually just go
ahead and sample that texture and figure
out what the normal actually is for a
given pixel on kind of a per pixel basis
instead of like a per kind of vertex and
then interpolation and then all of that
stuff so really powerful stuff and we'll
cover normal mapping of course
eventually in this series as well but
that's just a little bit of an example
and I could go on and on I mean there's
you know in physically based rendering
PBR entering was like you know roughness
maps metal maps there's all this other
stuff that you can do as well to define
what areas of the body should be shiny
and what areas should not be shiny right
and all that is is just just a texture
but really that texture is there because
we want to look up a value when
rendering a given pixel inside our
shader and that's kind of what a texture
is and again like to bring out
physically based rendering again to give
you one last example there are certain
mathematical operations that are very
difficult to do in real time so we can
actually do them offline and then store
the results in a lookup texture and a
lot essentially in texture right and
then all we have to do is or in that
texture we've stored all of these
already pre-calculated values we can
just extract the one that we want and
that's it we suddenly don't have to do
that calculation of runtime that's what
we do with like a brdf lot or something
like that right so that's another
example and we'll get into all that
stuff in the future in a lot more detail
so if you don't understand any of this
that's totally fine the point that I'm
kind of trying to drive home is the
textures are so much more than just a
bunch of colors that we use for directly
taking those colors and then applying
them to a 3d model all right so now that
we've discussed just what textures I'm
what they're used for in a game engine
let's talk about what we're actually
gonna do today specifically so what I
want to do is load an image file from my
computer and then I want to render that
essentially on like a quad inside our
engine that that's it I mean how hard
could that be
there's actually a lot of components
that go into that first of all we need
to talk we need to talk about our
geometry so what is needed to display a
texture on our computer spring right
like what data do we need in the
geometry and specifically what I'm
talking about is we need texture
coordinates again I don't want to really
go too deep into this check out the
OpenGL stories video on textures because
I think that goes a lot deeper than what
I'm going to do right now but
essentially what we need to do is modify
our vertex buffer so that it actually
includes texture coordinates for every
corner of our square then we also need
to have a wind change our shader around
so that it takes in like a sample A to D
which is basically just a 2d texture
slot and then we need to create a
texture glass obviously that will load
that file and create and upload it to
our GPU and also we'll get a render ID
out of that then we can just bind at
runtime using an API that will create
and then that I think should be it so it
shouldn't be too difficult but there is
a lot of work that's gonna go into this
I don't want to make this episode too
long so I'm going to just go through it
as fast as possible it should make a lot
of sense it should be really
straightforward if it's not and make
sure you check out that OpenGL text
video and if it's still not clear to you
leave some comments below and I'll try
to make additional videos for things
that that I might have missed that you
might be um that might just need a bit
more explanation so without further ado
let's jump in and take a look at
textures in our engine ok so the first
thing I want to do is prepare this area
kind of protection so what I'm even
gonna touch textures yet we're just
gonna
everything else basically ready to go so
if we take a look at what the hazel
engine is at this moment all it is is
this triangle I think I'll get rid of
that triangle it's getting a bit
annoying we've got this grid which is
fantastic we might keep the grid but
what I wanted maybe instead of this
triangle is a nice big square where we
can actually render out texture so to
render a texture we need to render it on
some kind of geometry so we've got a
vertex buffer here which contains a
square which is fantastic that's what
we'll use however what I'll do is I'll
hide this triangles this is us rendering
the triangle on this label it yes was
not clear this is us rendering our grid
literally all we need to do is take this
submission and instead of submitting
we'll change the transform around so
that instead of it being tiny I think
what we're doing is we've got a position
which is fine we can just leave it at
the origin however the scale we did set
to 0.1 we're just kind of small
obviously I think 1 1 is the size of
that triangle which is also a little bit
small so what I'll do is I'll just copy
and paste this scale transform it I'll
change it so that instead of 1 as 0.1
it's 1.5 so it's a little bit bigger
than just one point zero scales what
scaling it up a little bit will still
keep the flat color shader and the
square vertex right so if we launch this
right now we are setting the color to
blue here so we should just get kind of
like a large blue square kind of in the
middle of our screen and here we go so
there we go
we've got this Blue Square perfect so
now what we want to do is instead of
rented the color blue we want to be
sample each pixel from a texture so that
we actually see our texture on the
screen so to do that the first thing we
need to do is change up this vertex
buffer so that it contains texture
coordinates because we have texture
coordinates we actually can't render
anything because we won't see we won't
actually know which areas of the texture
need to be sampled so for the bottom
left corners is the bottom left corner
we'll just use 0 0 for the for the
bottom right corner it'll be 1 0 so
we're just going along the positive
x-axis here I'll just copy this quickly
for the top right corner
is going to be one for X and one for y
and then finally for the top-left corner
we're back to zero X and Westie o on one
y now this is expanded now instead of us
having three floats per vertex we have
five because we have two more for our
kind of 2d texture coordinate here let
me just check out that's right and yeah
that looks good okay so basically I mean
the way the way that you can follow this
is if the negative 0.5 is negative right
if the 0.5 is negative then the extra
corners should be 0 and if it's positive
then it should be positive it should be
positive 1 right so one for positive 0
for negative and that way we can quickly
check to make sure that everything is
correct and it is so we to expand this
now obviously we still have square
vertices and the size of square vertices
so we don't have to touch anything here
for our layout because of our beautiful
layout system all we need to do is just
literally add another add another
attribute here there's going to be a
float too and that's going to be called
a text chord all right
and that's it I mean if we just launch
the program now it should be it should
look exactly the same because we've
expanded our vertex buffer obviously but
we've also expanded the layout correctly
and the fact that we're not taking in
anything inside our vertex shader that's
totally fine because obviously the
position still remains at layout zero
and it still is a back three so if we
hit f5 to just quickly verify that
everything is correct we should still
see the exact same thing as before all
right and now we've got the same result
as before fantastic so what I want to do
now is create a new shader that's going
to be our texture shader
so what I'll do is next to black color
shadow I'll make a new shader that's
going to be called texture shader and
then what I'll do is literally copy and
paste this entire flat color shader
including the shadow creation like this
now we're getting a lot of shaders now
so it would be a good idea to start
thinking about some kind of asset
manager or some kind of shade and
library so that we don't have to define
all this stuff inside our sandbox app so
it's definitely something that we'll
talk about soon in the future so we'll
have texture shader bear text tools
texture shadow fragment source this is
going to be
extra shader this is going to be of
course our texture shader fragment sauce
and our texture shadow with vertex sauce
so great with credit a new shader now we
can edit this code and it won't affect
our blue shadow our flat color shadow so
we don't need to output position anymore
what we do need to do is actually take
in that second attribute which is our
vector which is all about texture
coordinates right per vertex and then we
need to actually get that texture
coordinate and send it to the fragment
shader so that we can access it there
and the way that we do that is the same
way that we were sending position before
we simply write out vector then V for
varying honors for text board okay
instead of outputting position here
we're putting our text board and then
this jail position that stays exactly
the same
so in the same way that we are put it
here we need to input it here so we just
use Ian's back to text cord now we have
access to that texture coordinate you
know our shader and now what we can do
is actually see if they're even correct
right this is a really important thing
for us to do because it lets us verify
our data what we're going to do is take
those texture coordinates and the same
way that we output our positions kind of
has our color in some previous episode
we're going to do the same thing with
texture coordinates here so what we're
doing is this is a vector right
we're outputting it as our color
specifically the first two components of
our color become this texture
coordinate' so the red channel and the
green channel correspond to the X
texture coordinate and the y texture
coordinate respectively for the blue
channel we've just call zero so we won't
have any blue at all ever and for the
Alpha we've just got one and that
doesn't change obviously at all so now
what should happen is if I render using
this shader what I should see is a
visualization of this data that I've put
into my vertex buffer so this is a great
way to actually verify that the data
that you've actually provided is correct
because obviously inside our shader we
can't print anything to the console or
anything like that because it's running
on the GPU and so the equivalent of
doing eyes
just basically outputting the color on
through the screen which is really cool
because you can also validate it
visually which i think is even more
useful than if we even could print it so
what we'll do now is we'll do the same
rendering but instead of flat color
shadow will use our it's extra shader
and we'll hit a 5 and see what happens
all right wonderful so now we have a
really cool gradient here that it's a
visualization of our data now how do we
read this we know that the bottom left
is 0 0 right the top left is 1 1 if we
look at what we've supplied for our
texture coordinates we know that the
bottom left coordinates should be 0 0
right that's exactly what we see we see
it being completely black which is 0 0
for the right side right so this is the
bottom right we should be 1.0 in X and
0.0 and why now X is being output as we
as the red Channel and then Y is being
output as the green Channel so we should
have 0 green and full red that's exactly
what we have here in the bottom bottom
right corner we've got full red not
green at all now if we look at the
y-axis what we should have is for the
top-left corner which is this we should
have no red at all and full green which
is exactly what you see of course we've
got full green or red and then finally
for the top right corner which is 1 1 in
terms of our texture coordinates we
should have full red and full green
which red and green mixed together give
us yellow so you can see how that works
now this whole thing that I've just
demonstrated is super important for you
to get a grasp on because this is how
you're going to be visualizing any kind
of data that you actually write in your
shader making sure not just visualizing
but validating any kind of data on your
shed and making sure that what you've
actually done is correct because as this
series goes on and we start exploring 3d
rendering and pretty lighting and
physically based rendering and all these
kind of rather advanced I guess shader
algorithms that are going to require a
lot of maths and a lot of mathematics
kind of validation because we need to
see mathematically not just visually
here's a reflective sphere cool no we
need to see visually whether or not what
out what we've written and all of our
maths whether or not it actually works
out and that might involve looking at
every
stage of our equation outputting it as
all of these values so that we can
actually visualize them as colors on our
screen and that's kind of what we're
doing here so this whole thing is really
really useful
pretty much every engine out there is
gonna have some kind of tool for
validating this like for example your
normals you might want to output a
normal instead of Eric rendering your 3d
model with full color you might just
random in all normals only so then now
you can see all the colors through 3d
model and that way you can validate
whether or not the normals that you've
actually provided are correct because if
you get some weird colors you'll know
what's wrong
so for example in this case if we messed
up so instead of making this one one we
made this kind of this bottom right
coordinate one one if I hit at five
you'll see a completely different
gradient and you'll know that it's wrong
okay so god is this smooth gradient
right we get this weird kind of thing
here where the bottom left of course is
zero zero but now that what I'm right we
can see is one one because it's yellow
the top right seems to be the
x-coordinate is on one which is correct
but the y-coordinate is flipped because
the y-coordinate is 0 we've got no green
here at all that way we know that's
wrong this is still right so really we
can tell just by looking at this and
this kind of comes with experience as
well but if you even if you don't know
what it should be you've never seen this
before you don't know what's wrong just
think about what it should be right
because I can tell just by looking at
this that this is your zero that's
correct that's zero one that's correct
but these two are flipped because this
should be one one so we should have full
green and full red which would give us
yellow but we don't this is where our
full yellow is all right and this should
just be read-only and not green rolled
so I know that these two are flipped if
we look at how we render this this is
like our first vertex and our second
vertex our third vertex and our fourth
vertex so clearly the second and third
vertices their texture coordinates need
to get flipped so these two which is
what I just changed B to get flipped and
of course we'll just do that by sending
this to zero and this to one and we
should get the same result as before all
right I never go that's perfect so that
is how you validate your data make sure
you do this pretty much any time that
you're doing kind of shader work again
nor
necessary for something as simple as
just trying to sample this extra and
render it on the screen but as we get a
lot more advanced in this series we'll
be relying on this kind of stuff a lot
in fact to the point where we'll
probably develop like debug filters
essentially which instead of rendering
our 3d scene they'll just render
everything as normals only or lighting
only or mana no vertex colors only or
stuff like that just to see exactly what
everything is and it could just could
even be as advanced as you know just
just render the environment map just
render I don't know just friend a little
ice with no huge baseline and just do
this and that because that kind of stuff
is really important for validating
pretty much everything we do because in
the world of graphics everything is
quite subjective isn't it right like I
mean I'll show you a little how do you
know that's lit correctly especially
when you're dealing with physically
based rendering how do you know that
it's physically based how do you know
this is actually this actually may make
sense like all about energy conservation
series that we've done they're actually
they hold true you don't know unless you
kind of visualize it and validate it
using something like this anyway let's
get on with textures so now we've done
that in the we we know that all of our
text recordings are working correctly we
can revolt to actually loading a texture
so to do that we're going to make some
new files in OpenGL I'm gonna make an
OpenGL texture class and inside render
I'm gonna make a texture class so we'll
start with that we'll just go right
click add new item we're going to add
two files one's gonna be a header file
called texture H and then we're gonna
also add a CPP file it's gonna be called
texture don't CBB texture CPP will
include our precompiled header and also
our texture header file and then inside
our texture header file which is this
one here we'll just use name space hazel
here we'll make a class called texture
now what I usually do is I'll split up
textures based on the type that they are
even though some textures like all
textures will have certain properties so
what I mean by that is we will have
different types of textures like this
could be a 2d texture it could be a cube
texture it could be a lot of different
things and because of that I still like
to refer to things as potentially
textures because textures of things that
have a like a particular width and
height they can be found all that kind
of can happen to them right so they do
have common properties
so what I end up doing is creating a
base class called texture which has
things like you know a virtual function
like get with all right which is where
we'll return the width of the texture it
might have it'll have to get high you
know we'll have get format and other
things that we don't really want to deal
with today and then we'll also have
stuff like bind right so we'll have
virtual void fine like that
so we'll kind of make this there's gonna
be real super simple it's not even going
to have any kind of like static credit
function because it's just a texture we
don't it's this is just a pure virtual
kind of abstract class it's not a
company instantiate it because it just
represents the texture now this is going
to be an actual texture it's gonna be
our texture 2d so what this is is a 2d
texture right and this will be a texture
but this will obviously still be
abstract just like alpha a text or a
class because it needs an implementation
by a specific renderer API which in this
case will be OpenGL so we don't need to
copy get with get height this function
that this do some class or this yeah
this class will have this class will
have all the you weren't override any of
these at all because they'll be
implemented in another subclass however
if there's anything specific to just 2d
textures that for example doesn't apply
to cube textures or doesn't apply to all
textures we would put that those
functions in here but really I think
because yet with get high bind that's
all we really needed we'll leave them in
the superclass here inside our base
class and then in our texture 2d 2d
class all I'll do is I'll just have a
static rep texture 2d right create now
what we'll do is we'll take in a file
talk in the future we'll expand this API
massively because we want to be able to
create textures just from memory we
might want to create a solid color
texture through my walk we might want to
have a texture factory that will create
things such as I don't know grids or
gradients or solid color something like
that because they can be really useful
to actually test out and and another
thing we might have is a narrow texture
that the engine generates so so for
example if
texture couldn't be loaded for whatever
reason the asset is missing instead of
crashing or displaying black we could
display like a very colorful grid maybe
or even a very colorful grid that
pulsates or something not and or
something crazy so that when you look at
when you launch your scene you know
immediately are that texture is amazing
like magenta is another thing that
people do for like missing textures I'm
using assets or anything like that so
there's a lot of things that what kind
of go in here not just necessarily
loading textures from a file path okay
so that looks pretty good to me I think
that's about it all we need to do all we
need to actually implement inside our
texture CBP file is that create function
so I'll copy the create function will
include hazel one clear two things will
include castlecore - and we'll also
include strange which is really both of
those things for this file and then in
here will create the create function so
texture to the create this returns a ref
so a shed pointer and then we'll
basically just go to like vertex array
and we'll copy a sorry not opengl Bettis
we're just our regular generic vertex
array and we'll copy this now this would
be a good time to also replace these
with wraps I'm not going to do that now
but that's definitely something you guys
should do for homework I guess and then
also something I'll do in some kind of
maintenance episode will include this
include two things so we'll include the
renderer dot H cutter file and also I'll
include platform up in jail OpenGL
textures of H which is something that
we're not going to wish something
something that doesn't exist yet but
we're about me
so OpenGL texture and then we'll forward
that path down like that and then of
course this will return it um especially
instead of returning new a new texture
watertown a make shed or in jail
texture routine and this will be this
will take that path in like that okay so
we end up with something like this and
of course this we're about to create so
over here inside platform open shell
I'll add two new files one is going to
be an OpenGL
texture age so I had a file and then the
other one's going to be our CPP file
open jail text read they'll say V will
include our PC H will include the header
file back in the header file will
include our texture so hazel hazel
Bandra texture and then we'll make the
OpenGL texture 2d plus there won't be an
Open GL texture gloss just texture 2d
because this will just be directly off
of texture 2d the reason we have that
kind of stupid generic base class is
because sometimes it might not matter
what the texture is it could be a
texture 2d could be a texture cube we
don't really care because a texture at
the end of the day is still something
that we can bind for example and use and
then it's not really if we might not
want to create two functions one for
cube one foot to knee to handle
something as simple as binding so that's
why we have that this will have a
constructor one thing I forgot by the
way the vessel destructor I'll add that
under second but we'll have it's taking
a path then we'll have a virtual
destructor opengl texture 2d
and then we'll basically implement
everything else so often we add that
destructor so virtual texture destructor
you'll just leave a blank like that or
we can actually set it to equals default
should be a little bit nicer and then we
just need these three functions so I'll
copy them paste them in here leave them
as vegetable replace the equals zero
with override get with and get high we
can immediately just set to return width
and height which will create a new
minute and then bind of course we will
just leave us a constant of ride okay so
we're time width and height looks good
to me
we'll make a private set of member
variables field I'll keep the path
around not something we probably need
too much at runtime it's useful to have
this for debug bills and for development
bills of your engine because for example
you might want to hop reload a texture
so basically what I mean by that is you
recreate your texture and then you just
save it and you exported again and then
you want to immediately have your end
pick up the fact that the files changed
and then load that in so you might want
to retain the path for that whether or
not the path should be in the actual
texture is questionable you could for
example have an asset manager that
handles hot reloading and thus it would
maintain you know a path like a map from
a path into an actual texture like
instance a texture object like this we
don't have an asset manager so for the
minute I'm just leaving the path inside
the open gel texture class so width and
height I'm just becoming UN 232 T's with
the name height and then finally we'll
have will have the same for a renderer
renderer ID okay and that's all we need
so if I just go over here and use visual
assist to create all the map method
implementations here we have them I
forgot to actually have the Havel
namespace we'll have to quickly fix that
up I'll just get rid of hazel from all
of these areas here okay and now
everything is pretty good so we'll set
the path to be the path and now what we
have to do is actually load out image so
one thing I'll do is just quickly
include glad because we need to access
the OpenGL API here and then now we have
the task of actually loading our image
now there were a bunch of libraries that
you can use you could of course not use
any library and just kind of load an
image write your own code Dakota now
technically speaking in an engine as an
engine asset you probably wouldn't rely
on any of the existing image formats
like a PNG or a TGA or a JPEG not sure
anyone who would use a JPEG but anyway
my point is you would rely on those
image formats you probably make your own
texture format which you would build
kind of a like build time through your
kind of build pipeline you create like a
texture and Photoshop and save it as
like a PNG or a TGA or a tiff or
something like that then load that into
your kind of build pipeline and build
that into like a hazel texture file and
then that's what you would load a
runtime in your engine that way it'll be
probably in like a more optimal format
that you actually care about when I went
on at the stage of building an asset
build pipeline in our engine yet so
we're just gonna load in PNG files for
now but in the future that will probably
be replaced so PNG files how do we load
them easiest way by far is by using
something called STV image s
she is like a library of various
a-plus-plus like helper classes
essentially or normally classes but you
know what I mean
utility functions that help us do things
in C++ for example load an image and the
STP image library actually it's a single
header file and it includes everything
we need to load PNG images JPEGs a whole
bunch of other formats so we're gonna
grab that off github and use that okay
so here we have the SUV library I'll
leave a link to this in the description
and over here we have just one file that
we care about which is STB image dot H
if we click on it you'll see what the
file actually is is quite large seven
seven and a half thousand lines but
that's it that's all we need to load all
of these image formats so we'll click on
raw here to just get the whole file then
ctrl a ctrl C to copy the whole file
we'll come back in to hazel what I'll do
is I'll actually put this into the
vendor folder so inside hazel and then
vendor I'll make a new folder called STV
underscore image and then insiders to be
honest core image I'll make a new item
which is gonna be a header file and I'll
call this the same file name as it was
in STP which is STP underscore image
I'll delete everything from this file
and paste in what we just copied now we
have the whole file here all the license
information of course is just here right
I mean this one is just afraid to use of
course public domain which is great
these are all the file types that it
actually supports so you know we have
TGA we have PNG I mean we even have jpg
and kind of I think a limited version of
the Photoshop file format as well so it
also tells us what we need to do to make
it work right so just somewhere we need
to define this and include it right so
that's what we'll do so we'll set that
up now actually what I'll do is add a
new item I'll call this STP image dot
CPP will include our PC H of course
because we have to and then we'll just
copy and paste this example code and
just paste it in like that
ok so there we go we've got everything
here we need to set up a few things
though in pre make to actually get this
to work properly so what I'll do is just
open up this folder in a file explorer
he'll go to hazel we will grab that
premake file put it in here if we take a
look at what we've done to other files
what we need to do is make sure
we compile this file this CBP file so I
mean we've added it to visual studio now
so it will compile but we also need to
make sure that it works with when we
whenever we want to regenerate a project
so what I'll do is just put in project
name vendor and then yeah I mean we
haven't done the whole bender folders of
course I'm not gonna do the whole vendor
folder we've done just GLM here so we'll
also do the same for STB underscore
image okay so about the seam key and
we'll also do the same for the header
file just so that it is thing actually
included in our project and then we also
want to include it as an include
directory so we can use it throughout
our engine so I think we had GLM here we
did kind of well this this little struct
of everything here so I'll do STP image
gear as well which will be hazel hazel
vendor STV image like that and then all
we have to do is inside our include
directories copy and paste this hello
comma and just do st be honest port
image okay so that's that should be
everything just to test that out really
simply we could just come to our hazel
the root of our hazel repository rerun
generate projects everything should
generate successfully and we can reload
everything in visual studio to see if
that worked so now two things should
happen first of all this STV image
should be included so we've got other
stuff there's not included like this for
example but you can see this stuff is if
we go to STV image LCVP we should be
able to hit ctrl f7 to compile just this
file and inside our output you can see
that this should complete successfully
and there we go so now that's done and
we verified that's working because we
added it to the include directories we
should also be able to go into OpenGL
texture and just type in include and
then STB image dot age like that and
then we should be completely fine with
that
right okay beautiful so now we can
actually load in that texture so how do
we use this to be image well the really
really the only function that we care
about well there's a few but um the only
one we care about is actually just SC bi
load right so that takes in a console
file name it outputs X&Y being the
dimensions of the image to the width and
height of the image that it's red it
outputs the number of channels in file
and there's also an additional parameter
at the end called desired channels which
actually lets us kind of convert the
image into the format we want so if the
image is like an RGBA the actual file is
like an RGBA we can convert it into an
RGB so we can read it as an RGB which is
pretty cool but usually what I do is
leave desire channels as a zero which
means it's not going to change the
format at all and then we'll just we'll
just see what the format is and then
react to that so and this returns an s2
bi you see which is just an unsigned
char pointer
okay so STP I you see for being all cool
and we want to use their types we have
basically our data which is our image
data inside load we'll just do path dot
C string to get the C string how about
path X&Y and channels and file are
output parameters so we'll do with
height and channels so we now pass in a
met the memory address of width height
and channels so that we can get that
data out of it side channels stays at
zero and if we take a look at this DVI
you see for fun you can see that all it
is is an unsigned char ok cool
so then we have that's it really if it
doesn't work out it returns a null
pointer so we can just do a check for a
set dot up and then be like you know it
fails to load image just like that to
verify it that's correct and then we can
continue on with everything else so scpi
load unfortunately gives us our the
width and height as a as a signed
integer non unsigned integer so we don't
have to quickly raise fine everything
and then channels will kind of just hold
on to we won't deal with that just yet
but that will be important for
determining the actual format of the
image when we upload it to OpenGL ok so
now the next step is to actually take
this buffer of data and upload it to
OpenGL I'll put it to our GPU so the
first thing we'll do is actually use GL
create X just to create context it'll be
a 2d texture right when it read just one
texture on the GPU and then we'll will
actually save that ID into our render ID
variable and then the next thing we need
to do is actually allocate some memory
on the GPU so that it can actually store
all this image data so we'll use GL
extra storage tree for that it asks us
about what texture
obviously general storage core so that
what our render ID is the number of
levels so if we had MIT maps which we're
not going to deal with right now we
would basically have to work out how
many MIT maps we needed and then put
those put those levels in there but
we'll just deal with one for now the
internal format being how OpenGL
actually stores that so you can change
this into what you want if we're using
for example srgb you would use srgb over
here we're just dealing with a normal
HIV 8 texture which basically means that
we're dealing with a texture that is a
GB and it has 8 bits per channel and
then I think that and then the width and
the height rise to M with an M height
and you can see OpenGL wants unsigned
variables here because it wants GL sized
eyes that's another good reason for us
to kind of store them as unsigned
integers now we've done that we can
actually upload the texture before we do
that though I like to set some texture
parameters which pretty much all
requires so Jill texture parameter I so
for our texture which is a renderer ID
we want to set a few parameters so
specifically we need to deal with what
happens when we render our texture on
geometry that isn't like a one-to-one
mapping so basically OpenGL will have to
either shrink our texture or expand our
texture so that's called minification
and magnification so gel texture min
filter means what kind of filtering
we'll use for minification we don't need
to deal with maps at the moment so we'll
just use geo linear for now and we'll
kind of see what happens and then we do
the same thing for magnification so if
we render our texture on geometry that
is larger that basically the geometry
will have more tap more pixels to fill
than the size of our texture we need to
scale our texture up what kind of
filtering do we use for that scaling up
we use linear filtering which will
basically just linearly interpolate to
work out what color we want okay and
then finally now we can upload our
texture so we do this by doing texture
sub image 2d and we have a bunch of
parameters here quite a lot actually so
render ID is the first one we have a
level to which level are we uploading
just level zero here because it's we've
defined one level and that's kind of the
index of the level
which is zero the X offset and y offset
because this can be used to actually
upload a partial texture so you can tend
you could change a region of a texture
that's already uploaded width and height
being M with an empire the format this
is the format of the data that's
incoming so the image that we'll be
loading will be RGB so I'll just type in
GL RGB you can get this out of channels
by the way and make sure that if the
channel says three for example its RGB
if it's four then it'll be RGB a so we
can validate that as well and then
finally the not finally but the type
right so this is the type of data that
you can each opengl it's just a bunch of
unsigned bytes right that's what our
unsigned char data is and then the
pixels right so this is where our data
pointer actually is okay that's it
that's done that's all the opengl code
we actually need so now what we want to
do is once we've uploaded the data to
the GPU we no longer need to retain it
in our cpu memory in the future you can
of course retain it if you want usually
you'd have like a parameter being like
please retain this when you create the
texture but since we're not dealing with
that stuff right now we can just do SD
pi/3 and then and I think there's a
specific function for this and I think
it's STV is an image free SC bi image
free which will free s DPI image free
and then we'll use that data pointer and
that will actually they'll actually
deallocate or free that memory that was
used to actually still there's a massive
you okay done
so inside our destructor will call GL
delete textures look like one texture
and it will be our renderer ID and
finally for bind what we want to do is
use GL bind texture unit so what this
will do is bind our texture right at a
particular slot or unit as OpenGL calls
it so we'll just be binding a slot 0 and
we'll find our and righty now this is
this slot kind of refers to what kind of
you know I guess texture you know we
bind our texture in to because you can
bind a lot of textures in fact you will
have to bind a lot of textures when you
render something more complex and then
you'll have to access all those textures
kind of at the same time in your shader
so because
we have texture units so that we can
bind more than one texture at once
typically you would want to actually set
the unit so what I'll do is I'll spray
it wasn't going to do this now but will
do it will create a UN 32 primer which
is going to be this lot right and that's
what we'll find our texture to that kind
of selects the slot that we get bouncer
over here I'll put this into binds and
then in texture duty as well I'll just
put this into bind and we'll have a
default parameter of zero just like that
and I can do the same thing over here
just so that if we don't specify a slot
it binds us to slot the zero okay cool
that looks pretty good to me if we go
back to our OpenGL texture class I think
we've got everything that we need to
actually render this let's load a
texture so what I've done is I've
prepared a little texture here it's just
gonna be a checkerboard I've put this
into into the sandbox in inside the
sandbox directory inside our hazel
sandbox I've made a directory called
assets and then textures and then inside
there I've created this checkerboard dot
PNG file which as you can see is just a
checkerboard right pretty cool this is a
really nice session tip test we can also
test whether on is the right way up
because the bottom left should be like a
black square and the top one should be a
white square cuz sometimes we can have
our images our textures uploaded with a
vertical flip which we which we wouldn't
want and this texture is just RGB not
RGB a and we can obviously validate that
ourselves if we need to but that's why
I've used show RGB here okay cool so now
let's just make sure everything compiles
first of all I'll just compile our whole
solution here by hitting ctrl v to beam
and I'll see if this works okay so we
got a few errors here we go syntax our
own texture because we haven't I think
we have either you have too many
parentheses here so we'll just fix that
up and we also have a new line in
constant so there's yeah we forgot a
closing quote yeah so we'll just
recompile with those changes and
hopefully we'll be good all right looks
good to me so now what we'll do is
actually load in that texture inside our
sandbox out so I'll come over here into
sandbox app I'll go to the bottom one
thing we'll do quickly before we do that
actually is going to our hazel header
file and just make sure that we're
actually including this so maybe just
under
I'll include hazel render a texture LH
then back in sandbox up I will make a
hazel wrap it's gonna be a hazel texture
2d and then we'll pull it em texture
then over here after we create all about
shaders I will come over here and just
reset our texture to be a hazel texture
2d create and and by the way you could
actually store this just as a texture
that's fine but we're storing it as a
texture 2d so we'll supply part which
will be assets textures and checkerboard
checkerboard PNG and now all we really
need to do to actually bind this is just
before we render our actual square we
just do combined and then we can put in
a slot or would you skip it a zero
before okay so that's everything done
from the kind of texture side of things
now we need to modify our shader to
actually sample from the texture
currently is just looking at those Tasha
coordinates which is great
but now what we need to do is actually
sample from the texture so we'll get rid
of this uniform which is just doing
nothing doesn't really isn't used anyway
that's how color and we'll change this
to be a uniform sampler 2d right which
means that this is going to be sampling
a 2d texture and we'll pull this do you
wanna score texture and then our color
instead of this will be texture which is
a function which lets us sample a
texture you on the spot extra will be
the sample that we're using so that'll
be a texture and then we need to
basically provide it with a set with a
2d coordinate of we're in the texture to
sample from so that is what our texture
coordinates are used for and that's what
we'll use here okay and that's it that's
done right that's all we need to do
everything should work it's really
really simple
so now what we need to do and the kind
of last unresolved thing is this actual
sampler right because this sampler is
not set it's a uniform it needs to be
set we need to set it from the tube from
from the CPU so what we'll do is the
same way we kind of set this up you can
see that we bound it and then we set our
you color will do the same thing I'll
just copy these two lines of code we
don't need to do this every frame
though let us put it over here we'll
grab this texture shader will bind it
and then instead of uploading a uniform
float 3 I'll just move this over a
little bit so you guys can see instead
of uploading a uniform flow 3 will
upload a uniform int and what this is is
our texture uniform which is a sampler
2d but a sampler 2d is just simply an
integer and specifically it is the
texture sloshed to sample from so
because we bound our texture at slot 0
right that's why we upload 0 as the
uniform int here because that's kind of
the mapping that we have now again
usually just to complicate things a bit
more usually you would figure out all of
the all of these slots when you create
your shader so when you create your
shader you see for example there are 4
textures you just add a pond shader
creation just just assign slots to
everything so this first the first
uniform will be slot 0 then the first
uniform texture the first uniform
sampler will be slot 0 that slot 1
there's a lot - that's all three down
and dust have forgotten about then when
you want to render a particular
particular texture and you want to bind
it to that uniform name it knows the
slot that it has to be and when you bind
your texture that's where it actually
gets a slot from from the shader because
that way you'll never have any kind of
our woops I set the wrong slot you don't
want to do that stuff manually your
engine will usually handle that
automatically for you and that's
something that we'll do probably around
the time that we actually create a
proper material system ok so that should
be it if I go ahead and just hit f5
everything should work now make sure
we're using the right shader which will
be our texture shader make sure we're
mining the texture yeah everything
should work
let's hit f5 and see what happens ok so
we did get a compile error now I did
forget that this doesn't actually share
the Krait used to return a pointer this
doesn't return a pointer which is really
nice because now all we can do is just
say that M texture equals texture career
C that's beautiful we don't need to do
dot reset and set the actual value we
just assign it to that shared pointer
cuz already as a share pointer right
it's a hazel graph which is awesome and
clean up our code quite a lot so let's
hit a 5 once again and we'll see what
happens and check this out so what we
have is our texture now there's two
issues with it first of all if we look
at the original texture blacks supposed
to be on the bottom but
on top because that action has been
better be flipped and that's just
because OpenGL actually expects our
texture to be given from a bottom to up
fashion whereas STB image by default
reads it from kind of top to bottom
instead of bottom to top so we need to
flip it the other thing is it looks very
blurred it doesn't look as sharp as this
now you'll notice here that I'm actually
at eight hundred and sixty nine percent
so I've zoomed in a lot and the reason
that is still so sharp is because it's
not actually filtering it linearly it's
just it's not doing any kind of
filtering at all so we need to actually
change our filtering type to get it to
be sharp so that's what we'll do first
of all so we're go to OpenGL texture dot
CPP we'll change this and we don't
really care about the minification
filter thus if we make it smaller
the magnification filter is what happens
when it gets scaled up so we'll change
it from GL inning out two GL nearest and
see what that looks like
if we hit f5 everything should now be
very sharp because it should just now be
snapping to the nearest pixel instead of
linearly interpolating and basically
resulting in a blurred image linear
linear filtering is great for like
images for example but definitely not
for a for something like this where it's
just two colors so there we go that
looks perfectly sharp now we just have
the problem of the vertical flip in the
future obviously we do want to expose
this to the API because you should be
able to set what kind of filtering is
used and whether that's like this kind
of just scaling kind of filtering when
we're minification and magnification
filtering and isotopic filtering
anything else like that should be
configurable so that we'll make it to
our API in the future but for now we're
just gonna leave it like this the last
thing is to flip there's actually a
really nice function called flip
vertically on Lord I don't even remember
it's STV I set flip vertically on load
and it's just an int flag true if should
flip so we set that to one before we
load our data and if we hit a five it
should now flip it into a format that
OpenGL expects which is bottom to top so
if we look at what the result is you can
see we have our black square on the
bottom our white square on top which is
exactly what our image looks like in
well I mean I'm using Visual Studio code
to preview images because that's how I
roll but in any
as well you probably see it this way so
that is a texture on the screen pretty
cool stuff
didn't take that many lines of code
either it's pretty simple to do and we
now support textures which is amazing
now there are a few other things I could
talk about such as like blending if you
try and load a texture with alpha for
example because we haven't covered
blending at all we haven't even enabled
blending it's just it's you're not gonna
see that alpha transparency at all
there's all these filtering things is
also supporting RGB and RGB a what about
srgb are there's so many things and we
will expand on this because as I said
textures are extremely complicated but I
hope you guys enjoyed this rather long
video if you did you can hit the like
button you can also help support this
series and everything I do on YouTube by
going over to patreon icon force
actually the channel this is now my
full-time job making videos for you guys
and I want to do the best job that I
possibly can I also want to stay in this
job as long as possible
without having to look for like work for
a company so if you could help support a
series that would be absolutely
incredible because it's people like you
that make this stuff possible as a
reward you will get access to many
things such as exclusive videos just for
patrons you'll get access to a
development branch where I've actually
done all this stuff already I'll show
some footage from the development branch
because this week I actually finally
published the kind of animation code
that ideas so that we actually have
skeletal animation working which i think
is pretty exciting so as I kind of
developed hazel in my spare time and
that's eventually where these videos
will head towards you kind of get access
to that code just immediately which i
think is really cool next time we've
certainly got a lot to talk about
I'll see you guys then good bye
[Music]